[Music]
in fantasy life news through embossing
submitted by Sheila from Singapore I
mean she was from Singapore the
destination point
fantasy fans transformed himself into an
elf with 32,000 dollars worth of plastic
oh my god so she's got the pointy ears
$32,000 of plastic sir is it reversible
fine excuse you usually in it so they're
just a permanent else now he could have
spent right 10k and got really dope
prosthetics then you can put it on
whenever you felt like it $32,000 I
think that's a decked out Kissel yeah he
can only work one it's like one month
under you he paid to be outcasted there
was that other dude that paid a lot of
money the Philippines to look like
Superman right there's a lot of people
all over the world paying to look like a
lot of things pursue your dreams but
some people just shouldn't don't sleep
anymore
wake up no I mean this one is like or
maybe the brochure you was presented was
just [ __ ] up like the plastic surgeon
was like euro all the ears that we offer
9 years whatever ears else is you know
give me that one that's new you know
like in these situations to like I think
like for me when I say yeah you do you
whatever it means that it doesn't mean
that I don't think it's [ __ ] weirdest
fun and I don't care enough it's not
gonna ruin my day it's what I mean yeah
I mean I'm gonna have an opinion about
it definitely not going to ruin my day
like when some people see stuff like
this right they look at it like apples a
[ __ ] [ __ ] decides he'll get help
like oh yeah he's [ __ ] weird but I
whatever he wants to be an elf and Angel
and I'm a fantasy being that his aim is
to look inhuman graceful so like a
character from legend be or maybe Lord
of the Rings oh this is what it looked
like before make sense already so he
already looks like an elf he looks good
there lately
he looks like a pretty [ __ ] boy yeah
like a lot of girls like Emma he's
pretty oh man
oh [ __ ] how he his surgery Oh grok oh
[ __ ] a mold it looks like Lord of the
Rings character yeah
ah he looks like from the Elven class
how do you get your [ __ ] ears active
there wasn't a report of him actually
having his ears like I've done like that
so I think these are still like costly
prosthetics mm well so I'll tell you in
a second this is a list of surgeries
yeah good features he literally could
you dyed his hair yes'm you put a Korean
guy like a model like a like a
high-fashion model yeah yeah he looks
like a Korean news okay I like that
barbell model Sablan chicks like the
same kind of look she this isn't that
bad secretary I thought it was going to
be some weird like ugly oh you look like
a really pretty guy like the Brazilian
dude oh yeah become a kpop star yeah
like he loved the weirdest [ __ ] if those
ears are real though that's kind of
extreme this is a laundry list of things
he's done
so he's I've done liposuction on his job
a nose job
full body hair removal he's had more
than 40 fillers he's laser laser skin
bleaching to remove freckles I just saw
that that Duplin West Hollywood is on
Botox and he got his eye color change oh
[ __ ] how do you do that thing to do that
[ __ ] medically unapproved so far the
treatment he changed his eye color from
a honey brown to a crystal blue but as
of right now they're great because they
still have to you still have to have
more procedures together crystal blue oh
great it's pretty cool that sounds
[ __ ] okay they don't use any
anesthesia so it's a really painful
process
oh I'm okay off that bag saying like for
the recovery you need like I job and you
need extremely black sunglasses
he said that initially watching the
stars in the sky was painful but then
three days later he felt normal
[Music]
so he says he spends about five thousand
dollars every month just to maintain his
look which is bleaching his skin and
hair he uses SDS 100 let me shave it
yeah but I got darkest fluffed Oh like
in Hawaii like when we out there I put
SPF 100 and I still came out Carolyn do
you burn though I did not add vetted
last time though so it helped out a lot
actually you apply every two hours
an important part thank you it was like
every hour or so but they do know when
we go snorkeling we're having so much
fun I'm not going to go back on land to
put some [ __ ] put the ash look SPF
ugh you know guy so I spit out there and
I got roasted that's what you get yes so
he also buys contact lenses and makeup
and product hair care products he's
planning on having surgery to make his
ears pointed his jaw to look more sharp
like a diamond the jaw he looks like he
wants a facelift and I live to have a
cat cat-like shape he wants to get hair
implants for a harsh heart-shaped
hairline like a Widow's peak typical
crazy-ass tractable woman I'm in instead
of being a short else he wants to have
he wants to have a limb lengthening
operation to make him that's what been
huge I know people have done that in
Korea back in the day would they would
they would take their femur chop it up
and they put a little brackets in
between and it would link him up only to
a certain extent though you couldn't go
like crazy long with it but you it's
it's very fragile so you can't actually
do a lot of the things that you want to
do like even I think like running too
fast will make it snap or some [ __ ] so
I'm gonna get off of that I know a lot
of women and trying to do that too just
to like get like better job a good job
position see that's ridiculous stuff is
I guess deeper heels
yeah because no because like there's
like a apparently is like a height and
weight requirement and weirder for you
to apply to like whatever job that
they're applying to and so it's like oh
you need to be at least this tall to be
a part of it like without heels so I get
a different job like a model game I
think it was like they're applying for
like secretary [ __ ] you maybe call for
forever secretary what the hell we have
highly cabinets all the way to the top
only that's why I need you to be tall
okay so we don't want me in Atlanta
secretary they're one of the first
people that other people get waiting
they do that in Asian countries Oh like
have you noticed the Asian flight
attendants they're always hot and young
because if there's like an age limit as
soon as you get to a certain age to kick
you out but if you go to the American
Airlines they have a seniority system so
they're always old like older you are as
the most superior job is so it's like
it's way different man this [ __ ] this
world that we live in broccoli
thank you finish she also wants to get
four of his ribs removed to have a
thinner waist so we can get suck his own
mm-hmm and he also wants to get muscle
there's no counter to take out your ribs
top up your like to get muscle inquest
so he's saying that when he was a kid
that he was bullied a lot
who's going to preventively a boy it
just makes it easier for them to kill
another you know so as a child he was
bullied for he used like these fantasy
tales as an escape from all the abuse
you she says that he would submerge
himself and fantasy movies like
labyrinths and the neverending story oh
the one with that [ __ ] weird doctor
ah yeah yeah my god today we have dog
didn't shoot fire this is such a bad
idea
can he just go on forums and meet other
like-minded people that likes the stuff
that he likes and just sting he says I
feel loved oh he loves them when people
stare at him now like he wants the
attention
I do I say maybe he missed the bullying
yeah my life it just doesn't feel bright
people are nice and she yeah cuz now
like what he what he does for a living
he sells cosplay merchandise he models
and he's also paid to make appearances
as a real life elf I'd even how is gonna
be my Christmas elf
yeah oh my god were you saying it only
work Oh like was here I was like no
match it's not gonna do some of these
cosplay people there's a girl I follow
on Twitter
her cosplay is in [ __ ] insane dude
like she's like both she would do guy or
girl so when I see her stuff it blows my
[ __ ] mind in she won't notice me I
want her to notice me what's your name I
actually don't remember her name all my
father explained it and I don't know her
Twitter name is I just see a pop up on
my face and I'm like that's dope she
probably won't ever notice you don't
cosplay people are like full of
themselves yeah
like I'm the shit's like hey how's it
going yeah nice try the following said
that when he was 14 years old uh some he
was determined to get surgery and at the
age of 20 is when he had his first
surgery and he's not planning on
stopping there do people date him is
that like boyfriend/girlfriend a good
question use anything you want to be
like a trans species oh god there's so
many categories ground a Liat a species
he says that he considers himself
transmission in the same way transgender
people feel I need to become how I feel
inside I don't expect people to
understand that I asked they respected I
respected yeah he says I don't consider
this an obsession but in fantasy you
have to have all the hope love
friendship and good feelings this helps
me to feel like a good person but in
fantasy you have to be beautiful not
only on the inside but on the outside
too this has changed my life for good in
so many ways I can't even begin to
describe it it means happy that's why in
the beginning of the story I'll just you
do you well if I'm saying is like one of
those things worse like that's [ __ ]
weird but all right I accept you berry
pie you're [ __ ] up just like one flick
on his rib he just explodes hey I want
to going on dente news fans hope you
guys like that episode remember to
follow our personal social media and of
course if you want to watch more videos
Mike and should go where to go your cos
occurs right up there
[Music]